[Music]
Lots of amazing people and carriages.The title of this game is the
magic of light and the hero's royal academy.The story is a familiar story in which the
protagonist enters the Royal Academy of Magic of Light and the Heroes, deepens his bonds with the boys he is trying to conquer,
raises his level, and eventually defeats the Demon King.
Sorry
[Music]
Say Eladolux
Level
99 Goodbye My Peaceful Days The main character
has the potential to surpass the final boss He is
stronger than anyone else in the party He can
use dark attribute magic that only enemy characters could use It's the best thing
You might not know.  But if you don't defeat monsters, your
level won't go up. Come on, come
on, you'll keep on defeating them. The
slow black
hole's blood is
burning. Mr. Yumi, are you the demon king
?
OG